the tip off local time just after 1
30 p.m gary harris to jokic and yokus
floats
over goldberg just a quick three in that
corner
neither team has missed on the
three-point line a wide open look for
millsap
he needed that just three of 13
in his most recent games from beyond the
arc now murray
into the lane sees gobert pitch it out
barton's
wide open for three and he nails it
after out rebounding the jazz 52 to 36.
so joking reverses bye-bye baby so
they're trying to guard jokic
with a smaller guy and then bring over
gobert to help nick mentioned seven for
seven
three-pointers between the utah jazz and
the denver nuggets now jokic trying to
back down derrick favors
and he puts it up and in favors has been
bothered with a bad back he's in today
watch him just make favors move his feet
right here takes the contact
gets around him then that's soft look so
coming to town the pistons
tomorrow wide open his jokic first three
is on the way and good
and he had quite the three-point story
at san antonio a couple of nights ago
top five defenses as
donovan mitchell is long millsap goes
and gets it ahead to yoke it's going to
ride it in
nope and he puts it back got a reward of
middle step closer to him tries to get a
little euro
just missed a little bit but then right
there for the tip
look like he almost set up on that side
and jamaica green has replaced paul
millsap now joking shoots another three
that's good
so joker two for two from distance he's
shooting 35
on the season biggest lead was 13 a
couple of times
now mitchell stripped joker
murray going to try to ride it in on
o'neal he does and scores mitchell he's
just
he's got porter where he wants him and
he thinks he can just raise up quick
on joker they'll either give him a still
or a blocked shot then the answer on the
other end good finish over o'neal
hampton two years from now he'll shoot
that's maybe
four to shoot another three by jokic
that's good too
wow go bear the two-time defensive
player of the year
inside jokic a little pivot put it up
and in not a great shot but boy what a
great result
clarkson having a terrific season as
joking spins it up and in and nicola
yokic
is on fire here and the first board
decides to blow on it goes in and
i mean that that's probably a bump and
foul there he just takes him for the
reverse
now jokic singled up he's got 10 to
shoot
in the lane around the corner put it up
and in
joke it's with a smaller man wheels into
the key that's good
for 26 now for nicola yokic
40 now monte morris
yogis going to shoot another three and
he makes another three
first bank halftime report is coming up
katie wendy bill hanslick will be there
jokic another little floater that's good
you know jokic coming in tries to scoop
it up got it back
with the left hand gets an extra rebound
we got baseline go bare i think he's
trying to pass it wait see he's waiting
for somebody to be at the
the top he said well let me shoot it
with
the left shoots up a little hard missing
let me just tip it in but
watch he's looking for somebody to be
right in front of the rim and there's
going to be a dunk there's nobody there
no one there so he switches it left
that'd have been sweet
if he just got that in and
capacitor is going to try another thread
and he nails it and you see they did
that just what i said
they're going to make capacio prove he
can make shots and so they double from
his man
utah is in a fourth quarter game on the
road which is what we said you always
want to be
right
jokic wheels in the left-hand lane is
good
jokish doubles down the middle compasso
throw it up and
in paso
watch this okay let's decide to do
something we'll kick it down no we'll
just dive down the middle and get it up
and then
compasso wants to get jokic on the block
here we go
compasso dump it jokic in the lane the
little bunny is good hippity hop
next time down has played two-man game
watch he takes it so deep both guys are
on him
joke is coming in and he scores
so he has tied his career high with
47 points also has 11 rebounds five
assists
to steal he's trying though nearly gets
it there yeah but what
nice too far on one side
today 47 points do you enjoy these
afternoon games since it's prime time in
your mother country serbia
yeah thank you thank you uh i'm just
happy that we won the game for real uh
just because it it was against the
problem at this moment the best team in
nba they have
they are playing amazing they had the 11
11
wins in a row there and they're shooting
the ball real well i think
it was a really nice uh win for us
we had a road trip we came back we had
three
or four testings just coming to arena we
had a lot of
excuses but we didn't we didn't buy and
we were just uh
we wanted to wonder this game and we did
you always take what the game gives you
the way defenses are playing you you're
shooting more are you actively looking
to get your shot up more
i don't know sometimes yeah it depends i
mean it just depends
what kind of game it is how i feel like
it's uh it's
um it's not that ice
oh my bad my bad it's not that i'm
coming to the game and
kind of i'm gonna do this i'm just see
what the game brings me well you don't
have too much time to enjoy because
tomorrow
you got your old friends coming back
mason plumly jeremy grant you looking
forward to seeing them again yeah yeah
yeah
i mean uh the now it's it's a different
role for them for of course but
i think it's going to be it's going to
be fun uh just uh just to see them have
fun a little bit with them
and mike and mike uh their assistant
coach he was with us too
joker you make the game look so easy
congratulations thank you very much
let's go back up to chris marla
all right a record tying night for the
great one nicole yokic
47 points